fastest man in the world what do people
say to you on the street when they see
most of the most of congrats and can I
take a picture anybody want to race you
yeah I get that that's the most asked
question to me I think everybody kids
old people young people What's it feel
like to run fast me that freedom feels
free you know I mean when that I speed
it it feels free and relaxed really well
I don't feel relaxed much fees for you
yeah have you ever gotten bored during a
race no no never gotten Boyd
have you ever ever slowed down on
purpose yeah definitely sure why no
sometimes you don't need to go as fast
win sometimes I can a championship sit
through the round to it only to run all
out sounds different reasons more
strategy in the 100 or 200 mostly both
of them in the same thing both of them
are same thing depends on dirait
sometimes you have to run hard because
you're running for time or sometimes you
just want to chill it out you know I run
to harden army so it depends are you
retired or kind of retired I have one
more year so I'm getting there so let's
go it kind of retired but there's no
chance of 2020 no that's too much work
I'm too far away
I'd be too old by then it won't be too
old by then in track here and tractors
what's more impressive what you've
accomplished or Michael Phelps
accomplished and I've argued this before
and I say that you don't have all the
different races that Michael Phelps has
but to be the fastest person on the
planet for 12 years is is a pretty room
double feed how do you explain how do
you explain it is just hard work and
dedication yeah I mean is what is what I
wanted so I knew if I wanted it I had to
work for it so I have a great team
around me and good coach that hosts me
to stay focused and just work towards
what I want so I just always stayed on
top when did you know you were fenced oh
well um I started to quit but I think
when I'll back 1516 when I really
realized that I had a great talent and
tirean did you ever think about longer
distances no never House never along a
difference personal cause you used to do
a long a distance in China and so it
wasn't it wasn't good for me Soho I knew
I was not good
can you run a mile in a good good speed
I don't know I've run a 800 already
night 12 minutes 12 seven seconds and
the girls would still be beating me at
the Olympics but but running a mile do
you think you can run a fast mile no I
think of 800 meters I'll probably be
dying what about football did you ever
give it any thought of playing wide
receiver because it was a topic every
Olympics we talked about you maybe being
a wide receiver in the NFL no no I mean
are you still watching when I was
younger and the hit set of guys used to
take I know it's not as bad now but it's
other guys would take it kind of turned
me off you know I mean so no I'm never
really thought about going but I'm
getting I've gotten offers and people
have asked me where do you keep your
gold medals no safety deposit box
don't even bring them out for any I'm
special occasion yeah today oh you do oh
yeah but I keep a close eye on them is
it around your neck
no how much pressure were you under
where everybody expects you to win
well I expect to win also so I wasn't
really that big of a pressure because I
want the same thing but there was
pressure because I know I had to do this
for the sport and stuff so for me it was
a better pressure builds into a
structural what's the pre-race routine
just normal warm-up the other thing that
I always do
I never changes that I made my cross
before actually won my start was one I'm
on my start so that's the only thing I
would say that's like a pretty routine
thing but normally is just simple
warm-up and get to the start how could
you intimidate me if I was one of the
competitors would you do anything I
don't know I don't try to intimidate
people you know I mean I do what I have
to do and it's good and compete honey
because I think China drives here and
somebody just ridiculous I can give you
a chaining you up there then is it noise
worry about everything is Usain Bolt the
movie is I am bolt and it's em both I am
bold hits theaters in November what what
do you want us to learn or take away
from I am bolt I just really wanted so
the background work I think a lot of
people I was most in people are
commenting into you know you make it
look so easy
I want you to see that is not easy the
way that I have to put in and all
started through all that I have to do
sponsor work and I just sacrificed a lot
and so I want you to see that it's not
easy it's a lot of work and takes our
dedication what do you remember about
the last time you lost a race last time
I lost race I individually was no that
was before the Olympics last year was
that Gatlin on my child oh yeah it was
yeah I was actually again I forgot about
that one
20 19 or 20 2013 that season I think I
was coming back from injury and I
with him in Rome and he beat me yeah all
that fun what you like after that loss
no you're wanting my coach taught me
before when I study got to those before
you can learn what win so for me losing
doesn't bother me especially if it's
just a one-off run it doesn't really
bother me because I know that there's
always room for improvement it's just to
figure out what I did wrong and then
improve it hanging I shall be fine
why is Jamaica so strong at the
sprinting events oh my god jesus said a
lot of things I said it's a yam it's
because of slavery but I personally
think it's this boys and girls
championship we get all rally together
and we really use them to do this is a
great job is like all mostly Olympics
for them we're all from all cons of the
country at least come dig in and compete
and that's where we see the talent and
and we take it from there and
development what are you gonna do when
you retire right now are there's a lot
of things that we watch out
I just don't want to stay close track
and feel um I'm still gonna work in my
sponsor boom ah I'm going to be
ambassador for life on our own
restaurant which we try to make into a
franchise oh well have a company that we
just started a Natur which is in insoles
and also I'm trying to work on a clinic
with my foundation to try to help the
less fortunate leads when they get
injured and stuff so so are things I'm
working on right now it's tried to get
up to the same level so they're all in
the pipeline and getting ready what
would you charge me to race you charge
you
oh my god would be too easy so and
charge I make it free all right I'd like
amazing so you tell me the time of the
place you're saying and all how much do
you think you you've never seen seen me
you don't know what kind of great
athlete I am but how many how many
meters would you spot me and you'd be
able to beat me in the
um
you sound kind of confident so probably
you run a little bit so I give you like
30 meters maybe 30 meet well I'm 60
years of anything oh and I'm white too
you say well you do some running its own
confidence I ought to be careful and
people self-confidence yes I mean they
do they do a little bit of run you know
some exercise so they're like yeah I
could do something you know I might
intimidate you though that's Mike get in
here I might get in your my slowness may
get in your head a little bit and throw
you off a little bit hey good luck with
the movie it was a pleasure watching you
not only in London also Rio got a chance
to do that in person in London but good
luck with that and safe travels thank
you all right thank you to same bolt
think he bowed out gracefully he didn't
want a piece of this
I like this they didn't know how old I
was then all of a sudden I tell no I'll
give you 40 meters he'd still beat me
yeah boy he's smooth you got a great
live eat an apple talk oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's good good stuff the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience